who understand what real numbers are all
you need to understand is the number
line positive numbers to the right of
zero and negative numbers to the left of
zero you will hear various complicated
definitions of real numbers but here's
the simplest one any number that can be
plotted on a number line is called a
real number let's look at a few examples
say - - yes it can be plotted on the
number line it's this point so minus two
is a real number
what about zero point five even though
it's not an integer it can be plotted on
the number line it will be somewhere
here now let's look at another number
root two which is also called as square
root of two if we calculate the value of
root two we get it as one point four one
for approximately the digits after the
decimal point do not end these kind of
numbers are called non terminating
decimal numbers and yes these numbers
too
can be plotted on the number line
plotting a non terminating number might
sound weird but yes it's possible
so root two is also a real number and
what about the special number pi it
approximately equals 3.14159 pi is also
a non terminating decimal number and yes
it can be plotted on the number line
which makes it a real number so that's
our definition any number that can be
plotted on a number line is called a
real number now let's talk a bit about
the different kinds of numbers we know
the first kind is numbers with
terminating decimals numbers like 0.375
the number stops at a point and does not
go on and on then we have non
terminating recurring decimals numbers
like zero point 6 6 6 6 and so on the
sixes don't end
it's called recurring since the same
number reoccurs and non terminating
since it reoccurs infinitely and the
third type is nonterminating
non-repeating decimals we just saw an
example of this type route to it
approximately equals 1.4142 and the
digits after the decimal do not end
hence it's called non terminating it's
called non-recurring since there is no
specific pattern of reoccurrence broadly
these are the three types of numbers we
see in mathematics terminating non
terminating recurring and non
terminating non recurring these two
categories together are called rational
numbers and the numbers in this category
are called irrational numbers these two
categories together form real numbers
this is the other definition of real
numbers rational numbers and irrational
numbers together form real numbers in
the second part of this video we will
look at all categories real numbers
comprise off